artnews is the news magazine of the art
world it has the largest circulation of
any of the art magazines and the
audience is composed of people who are
in the art world art world professionals
but it's also people who are outside the
art world who have a general interest in
culture and it's written in a way that
can it can be accessible to the people
in the art world and to the general
broad audience
while the process is a journalistic
process it's the same as any kind of
joint wealth in our news we have two
kinds of writing we have the feature
well which is the journalism which is
the report in which are the profiles the
trend stories the investigative
reporting that might be on art
restitution of works that were looted
during the Holocaust or antiquities or
something like that and then we have the
critical section the reviews the writing
is slightly different because in the
review section you're talking about
giving a value judgment of whether or
not this show was good or bad
well I think the role of art news is
kind of painting a broader picture of
all the people the institution's the
places that are shaping the world of art
so I think it's less maybe in terms of
shaping taste as on reporting all the
different things that are going on out
there
because i think that the writing is
excellent I think the writing is
accessible the way that we write about
art isn't based on theory I mean it's
not kind of through the lens of
post-modernism post-structuralism
different theory it's it's the right or
certainly know about those things but
the writing itself is clear and
accessible and it's another case even in
the criticism where we try and be as
accessible to the insider as to the
general audience